before we get started yes if I take this
home well I'll get arrested the Vince
Lombardi Trophy this is to ruin that's
the real one that's a real Vince
Lombardi Trophy I don't know if that's
the one that's gonna be given to the
Rams of the Patriots this weekend but
that is a real you wanted you want to
lift it the wall of our lives or the
worlds of your home no if you well then
I think we're then I think we're at a
crossroads here actually the crossroad
let me tell you what okay
sure I'm not a lawyer but I watch a lot
of law shows okay I got about 50
witnesses that see me hit my head on
your set oh so if you just give me this
I'll let bygones be bygones
so is it so it's a liability issue this
for me that turns into an even worse
liability issue I don't wanna have to
call it the shack eyes and show I know I
know that just give me this I'll put it
next to my beautiful I'm doing the math
in my head as to how much you be suing
me for personal liability as to how much
this trophy costs which I've been told
is around $22,000 well I'll be suing you
for 23 though you want to lift it
no I won't touch okay you sure you don't
touch it look bad luck for you know to
touch the trophy when you earn it
my father's always are you seriously
always just cuz you know like when
you're a kid you get the trophy from a
local local trophy shop sure you but
like if you listen to me guys you get
this you want to touch it
talk touches is bad luck you gotta earn
it right see that's why that's why I
like you know I like in the NBA when you
win the Easter kind of the West and how
they give it a little trophies I've
never tested never I never touched and I
never celebrated I remember Phil did
that too right he's like when you guys
won the Western Conference Finals of one
of the many times you did you never
looked a little sober cuz Bella checked
looks at the hunt trophy for winning the
AFC like it's a hood ornament he doesn't
want to just like I don't know what to
do with this this is beautiful
it's a beautiful it's a beautiful troll
do you do you get a rep because you know
NFL players can get like a mini replica
this to have I got four replicas of a
Larry O'Brien trophy and I go
my father because growing up he used to
always take my trophies and let me
celebrate it one or two days and then he
put him away so finally I got enough
courage to ask him why he did that and
he said he never wanted me to be
satisfied so after he passed away I went
and retrieved all my trophies from from
Little League high school college put in
a room in my house and I dedicated them
so now that I give you go you you get to
see like all my trophies but I would win
it I'd celebrate it one two days and I
you know maybe they would have dinner
and he would say thank you very much and
he put it there come back like the next
day hey dad let's go dinner like where's
the trophy I don't know go get another
one
and then you did yeah and then you would
and you would Shaquille O'Neal here on
the Rich Eisen show you're a Cowboys fan
as we know right yes sir so do you have
any take on what you think of the
current state of the Cowboys you pleased
with it you I mean I'm I'm a fan but I'm
not the fan that gets involved with he
should be fired you just said you just
had to wait your turn I was a Cowboys
fan because growing up playing football
football was my first love and I wanted
to be the next to talk Jones and then I
got hit by a guy your size cuz I don't
want to play football a boy and then oh
serious and then like a couple weeks
later my father came in with an article
he said if you only liked football but
you need to consider basketball and he
showed me the John contacts store where
John signed 15 for three I wasn't the
smartest guy in the world but I knew
that was five million a year yeah right
so that's why when I play basketball I
brought a lot of physicality physicality
to the game so you were when you tried
to play football you wanted it you truck
you were defensive and that's what you
were well I've been trying to put
football player I was tight in you were
almost higher because you know it's
amazing and my guy Brockman over there
will attest to it the number of times
that we hear about Gronk and the analogy
is always about you you got fouled
every game huh yeah and Gronk I you
could make the case that he is fouled
every time this was very
he's very physical but I think that's
what makes him great because he's he's
very physical and he doesn't stop I mean
I did a party last year this dude showed
up and he wasn't drinking he was
drinking water all night but he was this
dude has a motor he doesn't stop he only
knows one speaker grant well I actually
got tired looking at him and then I try
to and then I looked at me but he looks
pretty light he's the heaviest dude I
ever felt my life he's all muscle what
so okay cell shoved on my shoulder and
he started first he was doing all right
then he started humping my neck I had to
go do all solid all muscle so this is a
good part of your DJing
yes call checks one else okay and you
were invited when is it on Friday night
your friend or here in Atlanta yep
Shaq's funhouse yes okay
can I get it can I get it on list of
plus size and you don't need a list okay
just show up with my fit my face is rich
everybody knows Richards no I'm just
trying to say I mean Rich Eisen Oh Eisen
rich I know everybody by the way it's
I'm thrilled that you're here in person
usually you're just facetiming me in the
middle of the show just watching the
show and all of a sudden I look down it
says shaq faced you know you have great
poise cuz you never move I don't move
and like oh I know it looks like you
always give great points and I want to
face time to try to throw you off but
you have great poise well I know you
work with Ernie so I need to have a
certain standard you know what I'm
saying and he was I'm good
I appreciate we're really good thank you
do you have a take on who wins the Super
Bowl do you think Super Bowl fifty three
I I think some be a very entertaining
tiny game
it's kind of hard to bet against the
great Tom Brady but the Rams are hungry
they want it now
so they have a great young coach they
have a great young team I thinks gonna
be a very very entertaining it okay but
I can't predict in business no I don't I
just want to I just want to say Greg I'm
there um are you going I'm going
I'll be there
son my oldest son he's going with min
we're just gonna have a great time and
just won't see a great game how is your
sending this he's doing good really good
okay
he was he was scared when he was getting
the surgery so you know I've had I've
had ten surgeries so I try to tell him
stories so right before he went in he
started crying a little bit I said you
scared you say yes scared I said let me
tell you something it's gonna be a nurse
she's beautiful her name is anesthesia
she's gonna give you a kiss on the lips
and you're gonna fall asleep right there
is she I said she's coming in there no
no don't bother
she'll be there and you won't remember
anything he said what's her name I said
anesthesia yeah so I mean so he went in
did the surgery with five hours of great
surgery so when he woke up I was like
you all right yeah he's like I'm does
that do you remember any things I don't
remember anything I told you anesthesia
yeah
works every time works overtime works
every time but he's doing well he's
feeling so he's coming to the game he
come no house no come he's not coming
okay chérif O'Neill the dad Shaquille is
right here on the Rich Eisen show what
do you make of let's talk a little NBA
here what do you make of Anthony Davis's
agent making the move that he did
obviously LeBron chair is the same agent
it's at LeBrons agency everyone knew
that would Anthony sign with with a rich
ball that was a possibility that they
were gonna make this move I think if the
pelicans were playing a little bit
better it'll be a little bit
unprofessional to make the move but it
may make the players that may not make
the playoffs I think it's time and he
just told him that he's not gonna take
that extension which i think is a
mistake but I think it's a mistake
that's 240 and New Orleans is a better
deal than 240 in LA different tax
bracket you know just whole thing and
then you know I just want everybody to
compete you know instead everybody
teaming up and trying to
why don't you try to beat whoever the
bestest that's like me in Orlando
getting beat by Mike every time and say
you know what let me go play with
Michael Scottie rather than saying nope
I gotta beat him I gotta beat him and
then finally nine six we did beat him
and you know I know Mike laughs and he
came back well we beat him and then you
know in the West it's like me saying you
know me and Kobe early on we keep losing
let me go play with Popovich and Tim
Duncan intersperse you know in order to
be the best you have to beat the best
that's what I thought that's just not
the case anymore
you can club that's what - listen
growing up it was a lot of great sports
stories like Lakers Celtics cowboys you
know it was just like the guys that were
just out there competing being the best
beating the best and at some point the
best has to fall but the best always
stays on top for a long time like I
remember bird match it just going back
and forth and it was just great TV great
great for these guys yeah I know I know
I I loved it too but I don't I don't
think that day's ever coming back though
right I mean don't you think because it
just seems to me that that that you're
hearing Anthony it's an it's an obvious
play to get to Los Angeles
otherwise why open the window now for
New Orleans fans to be so pissed off
about it they already just apparently
removed him from the video of inch for
the team to be introduced the pregame
hype video for the team they removed
Davis from it you know he's hurt right
now anyway but they took him out because
they don't want him to be booed the only
reason to put yourself through two and a
half months of being a public enemy in
your hometown is to try and get out of
there right now so that's the move and
then there's an idea that Kyrie would be
willing to come now because he said that
he apologized to LeBron for not
realizing LeBron style before I mean
there's no it looks like that's coming
together right now I mean it may but you
know the question you have to ask
yourself when all those pieces coming
out of a can they still beat Golden
State I don't think they can I agree
with you I think this thing not sure is
there anybody right now no you know I
don't even need to finish the sentence
right no not for a while because Steve
Kerr hasn't planned
unbelievable basketball like it's four
or five legitimist Horizonte but they
play so unselfish it's a lot of team
with a lot of great talent but you know
one guy wants to hold the ball too much
one guy wants to shoot 43 so I mean
these Steve just have them moving the
ball and it's actually a excellent brand
to watch I got watch them many times and
they always played the same way and
Steph Curry is just unbelievable and KD
you know Jesus they don't they're
they're definitely a tough team to beat
but again when you're dealing with
sports I want a team to challenge them
and to try to be able to beat up on them
imagine like the underdog like Milwaukee
facing them in the final and beating
them that's a great sports story that we
can always tell yeah seven games though
right that's that that's the issue I
mean like again Brady's here in his
ninth Superbowl his first all he had to
do is just four quarter against right
nine so does that make him ago oh yeah
[Music]
when you agree oh yeah oh yeah I mean
nine and he's doing it at age 40 and 41
back-to-back Super Bowls and you know as
you pointed out about super teams he's
done it with different running backs if
he did have Randy Moss at one point and
almost went perfect but it is just those
four quarters in the same way the four
quarters he came up with against Curt
and Marshall Faulk and Isaac Bruce Tory
Hall to win his first same could happen
for golf and everybody else this weekend
it happened for Eli twice I mean it
happens that's the reason why I love him
because he never panics when the super
book was when they were playing the
Falcons I was sitting next to my dear
friend Willie McGinest and we were
sitting in a box and there's a whole
bunch of Falcon fans and of course they
were a big
we'll eat at me and said watch this what
do you mean you guys gonna lose head
watch this like he look like he knew Tom
was about to turn it on and then and
then after that I was like wow he's the
greatest I mean like Willy knew the
whole time he called his shot down
because you know the guys from you know
500 fans they were celebrating and
drinking and uh we'll just have a nice
night watch this hey watch what watch
Tom go off and like I'm looking at Tom
I'm looking at his face mine's me have a
great population or Phil Jackson but
never panic and coachbuilder checkers
that way even twenty eight seven but
down twenty eight points or whatever up
twenty eight same face never panics and
that's why I think he's the greatest Tom
Brady Tom Brady you think and then mean
and it's the conversation to about
Jordan and LeBron who would you take
there how come Kobe lamb is little
brother okay all right all right no I'm
just asking you know that's a good point
because I think it's kind of
disrespectful I just by the way you and
Kobe being simpatico is a great thing I
don't know what some particle means but
it sounds good yeah they're related
being you know on the same page some big
words you throw another friendly
I mean you won't use our words of a
choice would you like to be simpatico
please do that yes 100 particles Wow yes
simpatico he wrote tight you're tight
I'm 47 years old I've never heard that
word my life is that right
simpatico please use that drop that on
Charles tonight if he said something you
agree with you know Charles were
simpatico on that that's what you say if
that was on the test and I was that what
is simpatico ottoman oh yeah a part of a
symphony perfect yes some part of all
right so Kobe LeBron Mike Mike Sports
Talk I'm not I'm not in that category
I'm not a knight okay no it's crazy but
I've never wanted to be the best I want
to be the most dominant well that worked
like I worked hard enough to be dominant
I didn't I didn't work hard enough to be
the best like I never because I was like
you know Jordan and Kobe and LeBron that
they got to do things I couldn't do I
wanted to be a force in the middle of
that if people were afraid of so like I
don't get offended when people do not
put my name in that category cuz that's
not what I was looking for okay so after
three if you had to choose one is the
greatest of all time wouldn't you
I don't like choosing cuz I know all the
guys but for me I seen Mike do some
things that I've never seen either other
guys bill and what is that I mean Mike
he's just used to tell the pawns what he
was gonna do and how I was and how he
was gonna do it ain't no the way he did
he just you know he won he won six
without a dominant big man right hmm and
you know he's even won three left took a
year off played golf play baseball came
back and won three more so I mean he was
just a guy that I grew up watching so
shirk nah I played with Kobe and played
with the Brawn but uh if I had to pick
the berries well I thought my my
all-time favorite has always been dr. J
so you know dr. J and guys like magic
and Mike Mike made a great point he said
it's kind of disrespectful to say I'm
gonna go because you forget about the
ones that you know play before us and I
kind of I'm kind of on that same thought
process so I give a will and Bill
Russell and guys like that I'm I'm just
happy to be mentioned in the same name I
think you deserve it and now before I
let you go sir are you an investor in
the Alliance of American football my
Shora
football football doesn't stop out there
this weekend it starts back up in
February and it's running on a team's
400 players eight games to watch level
our ears coaching you got the ol ball
coach on the sideline therefore
neuheisel assume you have a lot of
football fans in the
in the stands check it out yeah a lot of
NCT SEC team oh my gosh of course you're
an SEC country you got it Georgia is
that your wife sir you should be ashamed
of yourself married to a 20 year old
Shaquille O'Neal everybody I love it you
are the man so you could argue owning a
team or you just you just check I mean
are you gonna be an owner like in the in
the suite in the booth okay okay
I look forward to seeing you don't go
good to thanks for coming on here and
I'm gonna make you fumble on your show
under any time well what I'd love to do
what I what I'd love to do is have you
when we come back and the television
audience throw footballs through that
hole over there let's see is it
fantastic because Kurt Warner only got
three deshaun Watson got four and I'm
gonna balls were good 10 good same free
throws rich the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience